this program is brought to you by Emory
University today I decided to speak
about some work that is done in in my
lab mostly by two groups as a group of
Daniel Scott and Gavin the group of
Elisabeth menu because I thought that
many people are already in the room
knows a work of Michaela on African wind
monkey and you you you were also about
the work done by John Franco poncino and
as year Sicilian regarding the elite
controllers so I thought it was a good
opportunity to speak a little bit more
about the work on NK cells in particular
on crosstalk between NK cells and
dendritic cells during HIV infection so
for those of you that are not so much
aware about what we know during HIV
infection about the NK DC crosstalk as
this slide that I got from a recent
review of markers are 12 which is
summarizing quite well what do we know
about these crosstalk and of course you
know that it's a both direction
crosstalk which is important NK cells
are capable to activate classical and
then Hritik cells but also plasma see to
it dendritic cells and I know return the
dendritic cells are also playing an
important role in activating dendritic
cells this activation is involving
pro-inflammatory cytokines eye
stimulator NK cells and the PVCs
producing type 1 interferon that's
promote NK proliferation
and cytotoxicity we know that during HIV
infection the crosstalk between
classical dendritic cells and NK cells
is attenuated we know also that during
HIV infection NK cells are less
responsive to type 1 interferon and of
course you know that this crosstalk is
very important for promoting and and
governing also adaptive immunity so it's
a reason why we started to be interested
in our lab regarding the impact of HIV
infection on this crosstalk particularly
since we know that in order to control
HIV infection dissemination and
pathogenesis we know that we have to act
very early as this slide from originally
from Ashley Haase is telling us we know
that indeed we have to act as soon as
the virus is crossing the barrier and to
avoid local expansion dissemination and
the establishment and reservoir and as
you just said our lab is very
interesting in in studying model of HIV
natural control of infection to try to
contribute to the identification of
correlating having protection and we
have really believed that understanding
better the early events is a critical
issue among the natural model of
protection as you just mentioned we have
been interested oops we have been
interested in in expose non infected
individual but before showing thats work
and exposed an infected individual as we
remind me what is known from a
literature we have already evidence for
the role of NK cells in preventing
disease progression itself we
there is a decrease in NPSL function in
HIV infected patients we know that NK
cell functions are preserved in HIV
infected patients with low cd4 count
without such boundary infection we know
that there is an abnormal NK cell
repertoire during HIV infection and a
good correlation between low viral load
normal and T cell function and high
expression of NK cell receptors has been
reported in the literature we learned
also that there is an association
between TF 3d s1 and the low progression
to s what about the role of NK cells in
preventing HIV infection so we see this
is really houses story let's say started
we had as you know we have been working
with with developing countries for years
and in particular with country in Africa
but also country in Southeast Asia and
at the beginning of the cooperation with
Vietnam we had that idea to establish a
cohort of IV drug users to try to study
the IV drug users to try to develop
studies and on clinical trials and so on
however when we were trying to establish
a cohort we find out whether a very nice
interim observation we found some
exposed uninfected IV drug users in
Vietnam and the in the study we made we
study 45 Expos non-infected drug users
38 males seven females I mean age where
47 years old the risk factors that were
all sharing nickel needles and they were
using drug by intravenous
since between 13 and 31 years there were
all hpv-positive HCV positive and htlv1
positive but there were HIV negative so
we started to wonder why those people
were not infected in that study we used
as control blood donors from vietnam as
well as hiv-positive IV drug users we
first found an increase of NK activities
in the Vietnamese exposed and infected
eye videos you dog users that was
related to high level of NK cell
activation and we found modulation of NK
cell receptor in in Zoe's an individual
and to summarize the data that were
publishing in Journal of immunology in
2003 you can see on this slide
when we compare next exposed an infected
individual to Elsie Donna to HIV
negative IV drug users and then several
converted and HIV positive and V drug
users you can see that even without
stimulation of the NK cells we were able
to detect and activation on these NK
cells that was even higher after he 562
stimulation so we started as I said to
make studies and this activation of NK
cells in the Vietnamese you you can see
the kinetics here of the granulation by
following the CD 107 a degranulation
markers and you have the curve here
showing the exposure and in fact
compared to LCD donor you can see the
level of the percentage of cells
expressing the degranulation markers we
look also for for this the percentage of
cells expressing the degranulation
markers and you can see here a
significant increase of ourselves in the
exposed and infected individuals so see
we thought that the NK cells from this
exposed and infected individual may be
armed indeed in vivo to generate a rapid
and effective response to HIV one we
started also to study whether the
activated NK cell at the particular NK
cell receptor profile and this is a
summary slide showing that indeed there
is a net origin et in in NK receptor
expression among exposed exposed and
infected individuals for example here
you can see when we look for NK p 30 we
could not see too much difference
between our sadhana there is an
uninfected IV drug users compared to HIV
positive IV drug users that show what
has been reported in the literature a
lower expression of NK p 30 no Nouriel
differences between HIV positive IV drug
users and control regarding the
expression of the transcript of key L 3
RDS 1 and 1 but you can see on this life
that he was an increase of ratio between
here 3 d s 1 and q 3 dl 1 in HIV
negative IV drug users interesting me
also we found the percentage of of CD
161 was expressed I highly on the CD 107
a south of the Nanak the non infected
individual even without any stimulation
we can significantly show an increase of
expression of this receptor so suddenly
heterogeneity in in NK receptor repair
12 among the IV drug users as at the HIV
negative in Vietnam a balance of n here
and K are expressions that were in favor
of NK cell activation and this work was
reported in blood in 2007 so we started
to ask as a question whether C sub NK
cell repertoire is selected during the
crosstalk between NK and dendritic cells
during after infection of dendritic
cells and so we started to establish in
the lab the near Scott team started to
establish an in vitro model using
autologous co culture of ankle cells
from LC donor mixed with dendritic cells
from the same donor and then Hritik
cells that we in fact are not by HIV one
in order to study of course what are the
impact of the infection on the
expression of NK receptor on NK cells
and you can see on this slide the most
important data that we found is that we
had a decrease of C D 85 chain
limitary receptor on NK cells a clear
decrease when the dendritic cells were
infected we had a decrease of expression
of this inhibitory receptor we looked
what is the impact now of infection the
impact of sub population of NK cells
Weathers expressed as Xpress CD 85j and
the sub population that does not express
a cg 85 chair on the infection of
dendritic cells by itself so you have
the data on this slide showing that
indeed this is a study done using a gfp
virus HIV one but we are data also you
simplify following years a p24 antigen
in the cultures that are very similar we
found out that the subpopulation of
cells expressing CDA t5j was capable to
control the infection of dendritic cells
my HIV one of course when we used a
total and gives population we had also a
slight effect on the infection of
dendritic cells but most important
effect was seen with the CDA f IJ + NK
cell population we started to us whether
we will be able to rescue it's a the
infection by blocking the ligands of a
CDA f IJ on dendritic cells and for that
of course we use monoclonal antibody -
class 1 molecules and you can see on
this slide on the bottom of the slides
that indeed when we met blocking
experiment using a mixture of
monoclonal antibody against each other
class 1 molecule we were not able to
totally rescue the level of infection we
then took recombinant CD 85 chair
protein and we found out that in that
case we were able to suppress the
control of infection
so let's make us starting to think that
it could be another ligands that
actually class 1 that could be involved
in this process of controlling the
infection of dendritic cells by the sub
population of NK cells expressing cd8 T
Phi J so these data has been published
but to make a long story short this is a
summary indicating that indeed for
controlling HIV infection of dendritic
cells you have several mekinese to be
considered the classical mechanism of
course of NK cells that can kill the
dendritic cells that are infected by HIV
1 then Yun also found out that the cd8 T
Phi T - subset of HIV 1 was secreting
chemokines that able to block the
infection by f5 viral viruses of
dendritic cells but then we have been
mostly interested also to find out
what's going on with a subset of NK
cells that Express cd8 T Phi J how they
are capable to control the infection of
these cells so indeed if we consider NK
cells in HIV infection according to our
data and that are from other in the
literature you can keep in mind that
those NK cells can have both a positive
role and a negative role in HIV
infection so positive
get it war is a report mostly from the
group of patrice debris in france
indicating that the NK cells can be
cytotoxic for cd4 cell to fatty cells
during HIV infection the positive world
is at the fact that we found this
activity of NK cells in the air exposed
non infected individual and the
implication of particular subsets of NK
cells might be to consider since daniel
has been developed this model of
co-culture autologous co-culture we have
been asked indeed originally by the
national agency of his visit for the
program on vaccine to to study what can
be the response to a vaccine candidates
of the NRS program so we started the
work using the same model to study the
NK response to one of the vaccine
candidate developed by the NRS
recombinant MV a vaccine candidate for
some of you that know our national
agency for his research was very much
focused in the past in using as vaccine
candidate lipopeptide to try to
stimulate t-cell response by aleppo
peptide the lipopeptide are containing I
mean corresponding to peptides that
cover gag amino acids that are mentioned
in this slide as well as Neff as well
and and poor and there is a little
fragment which is designed for cellular
targeting but during the last year also
our National Agency for its research is
certainly diversifying the approach
because we of course we're sure that
Lippo alone we
never worked as a vaccine and the idea
was to combine my a prime boost approach
lipopeptide with other vaccine
candidates one of the the candidate is
HIV one recombinant MVA as that is
expressing indeed gag pour and F and
covering most of the region that also
covered by the little peptide so what
Daniel is doing or did is to add this
methodology is to isolate from blood
donor the NK cells and the CD let's say
56 positive cells to freeze the cells
and and then to isolate a CD of 14 plus
cells to culture in the presence of
gm-csf and i am for in order to have
monocyte derive dendritic cells we then
in the co culture use then with the NK
cells in mixed culture with either
dendritic cells infected by y-type MVA
or recombinant MVA and then add fresh
dendritic cells and after 18 hours of
incubation of infection indeed we add
the NK cell and the French dendritic
cells we study the activation of NK
cells NK cell proliferation by a CSF v
CF s e NK cell repertoire and k we also
look for control of HIV infection in DC
by either flow cytometry we using a gfp
virus or by following a p20 for
production so in summary let says that
we are data showing that HIV want
recommended in VA is capable to infect
the lytic cells in vitro that the MV
infection is in use
the service is within 24 to 48 hours
leading to and when we mix with a fresh
MVC we as FICO cytosis of dead cells by
uninfected DC resulting me in cross
antigen presentation we found a district
this year cytokine profile to exposure
to MVA but no real difference between
white type and recombinant MVA the NK
cells capable to proliferate after Koch
ultra with disinfected by NVA
where an NK stimulation by infected M
disease which is contact dependent and
space seems to be specific for HIV and K
cells show also another receptor
expression after exposure with MV a
infected DC I do not show the data but
we have differences also between the
donors I must say and while wondering
whether in fact it could not be an
impact of the genetic polymorphism of
some of NK receptor in the response to
mV a vaccine candidate recombinant MV a
stimulated NK cells
seems to be better in controlling HIV
infection in MDC in vitro in vitro
compared to the white-eyed simulated
gene we have been interested to extend
our studies on peripheral MVC's on
something I thought that you might be
interested to to hear it another model
of protection that the group of
Elizabeth Manu is working in my
laboratory since many years she's
interested in mechanisms that can
control the infection of HIV one at the
maternal fetal interface as you know the
transmission of HIV one during
in fact very rare and it's mostly with
infection without any integrity overall
treatment is mostly during the late
phase of pregnancy and mostly at
delivery so we have 90 percent of
protection naturally and we don't really
know the mechanism so because of this
low HIV infection in utero we have been
interested in trying to understand the
network mechanism of protection as a
maternal fetal interface Elizabeth has
work in the past at the level to try to
understand what was going on at the
level of the placenta and more recently
she has been interested to study what's
going on at the level of a deceiver if I
summarize the data which is known from
the literature we know that regarding
the passage of cell-free virus across
the placenta Maria
we know that cell-free virus is not able
to cross the placental barrier but we
know that if we use maternal infected
cells like for example maternal blood
cells then you can have transmission
across the placenta Beria it has been
reported in the past that doing this
infection by cell associated virus you
have a selection of viral viral variant
of HIV one we reported in in the past
that the balance between poor and
anti-inflammatory cytokine might be
might play an important role in cotton
in controlling the passage of the virus
across the placenta Maria and Elizabeth
also reported in collaboration with
Cameroon that Co infection by malaria
might increase
the passage across the placenta berry
but as I said more recently she has been
interested in decidua why decidua
because indeed nothing is known nothing
is known but what is known is that the
local site in the decidua as a
particular phenotype we know that in the
decidua you are 70 percent of the cells
that are NK cells and we know that these
NK cells of particular phenotype you
know we know that about 10 percent of
the cells are T cells and we know that
20 percent of the cells are antigen
presenting cells so Elisabetta has first
started to study what is the
permittivity of infection of the digital
cells to HIV infection either to f5
viruses or 2x4 viruses and that I
summarized here she got a low a virus
projection but she found out that the
APCs are capable to be infected by f5
viruses with T cells could be infected
by x4 but no infection of course of
decidua NK cells so in the perspective
of this work both regarding the NK
response to an arise vaccine candidate
and both to study and maternal-fetal
interface and the role of deciduous and
KCl in controlling infection as I said
most of the study right now has been
done in vitro and the relevance of what
you can find in vitro it's always a
question mark and of course we would
like now to start to make study on on
animal model and obviously we are going
to start to make study and primate model
the vaccine in iris vaccine candidates
are tested in preclinical trial in May
Jack and Danielle is going to start to
make study and on NK response in in
tones macaque and Elizabeth is starting
to discuss with Raja logo in false also
to start to make study on macaque
regarding the role of DNA in the control
of HIV infection at the level of the
decidua so thank you very much for your
attention
I just wanted to thank their work the
work of Elizabeth which is here in the
middle together with a group most of the
work was done with Martellus michelle
maher you know yes but also for mohammed
is pg and on this world the work of
Danielli in the lab together with his
collaborators on Savino Cummings and
then saw Arnold and the I would like to
thank the Vietnamese team because his
work on NK really started because of the
observation in exposed and infected
individual originally I did not speak to
their about some work also done on NK
cells and and clear response to Tuco
infection of TB and HIV this is done in
collaboration with the Cambodian team in
particular with pin Paula Deen here in
the middle but it is making his PhD and
his work and to make very story
long story short parody I found that the
degranulation markers 107a it's a very
good predictive marker of immune
reconstitution syndrome in patients that
are Co infected by HIV and TB in
Cambodia
so thanks also to the patient that has
originally participated to this research
in Vietnam and to the Earth's
professional that are working with us
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University